this is one of the reasons why i'm so
glad that i tested coveted negative
because i did not want to miss this
interview today just saying katie's here
brian cranston is here even here i did
not want to miss you today katie tur
msnbc anchor katie tour also known as
tony's better half opening even he says
that he's underlying better yeah he's
opening up about her childhood her time
in the news business katie by the way is
the daughter of a fame los angeles news
helicopter pilot who was then known as
bob tour
bob
she has since undergone gender
affirmation surgery and she's changed
her name to zoe so in katie's new memoir
it's called rough draft she describes
violence and the abuse that she says
were triggered by her father's temper
ref draft we have to tell you is
published by simon schuster that's about
part of our parent company tony's also
written about his dad his dad went to
prison quite a smuggling marijuana
family boy they had stories to tell so
we asked the two of them to sit down for
a candid conversation about how do you
describe unique upbringings
um so we're gonna sit down and talk
we're gonna sit down we're gonna talk
[Music]
i don't know how to start this because
usually i'm the one interviewing and
you're the one interviewing so it's just
kind of are we going to get into this
weird awkward pause i was thinking since
your book includes so much information
that you never brought up in our actual
marriage would you have not married me
had i told you all this stuff no i would
have married you i think you know that
was a long no
i guessed from my own background that
you might be tired of talking about your
wild and crazy childhood and so i said
to you i hear you have a crazy family
too something to that effect yeah the
people that i dated before i mean it's a
wide variety of people but you know they
they came from
homes with big offenses and
happy families it wasn't what i grew up
with and i always kind of felt like a
bit of a fraud
like i didn't really belong and so with
you when you said that i thought oh
we we understand each other on a
primal level we both belong it was a
relief
i knew that your parents flew
a helicopter and then your mom was the
camera woman and they were a two-person
news team and they'd shot really
historic stuff o.j simpson is believed
to be in the white bronco they had all
these ways to scoop the competition my
dad was always
one step ahead and he would dangle it in
front of the competition and say you're
not going to get the shot i am and they
all thought he was
a jerk no you don't there's
lots of clips on that archive of him
fighting with cops because you're
nothing but an imbecile and then also
fighting with your mom
so the fighting with the cops and the
fighting with officials i always kind of
looked up to i thought like this is how
you act as a journalist you push back
you push push
the fighting with my mom
i didn't like but it felt like i guess
this is just what marriage is
it felt normal
and this rage is not just
words
no my dad it came out in in fists and
thrown batteries or thrown keys or
holes in the wall
and
you know there was
there was the belt if my brother and i
misbehaved and it was ugly
when my dad was transitioning
she said that
everything would be better because the
rage would be gone because the rage was
all because she wasn't her
self and she told me bob tur is dead
bob tur is dead
and i wasn't ready to bury bob tur
i wanted to talk about all of the rage
and the anger and the violence and the
scary moments because i felt like if you
want to transition
into a new person i'm i'm all there for
you i'm with you let's do it but let's
let's talk about what we need to talk
about so we can all move forward so we
can clean the slate
you're off kilter looking at that
archive there's that one video
see it's my parents last flight and it
just feels like the end of everything
good crushing such a crushing video
you're vertical
my parents career is falling apart it's
my dad falling apart
it makes me want to
hide in a corner and put a blanket over
my head and just cry because it's it's
so sad
my mom
and your mom are very similar they were
both on this great adventure yeah and
the adventure had a lot of fun
and a lot of excitement it was also very
abusive relationship yeah
you saw a lot more than i did
i don't really know how to broach it
with you also i didn't want to talk
about it
who wants to talk about all that
ugliness
i mean how often
i don't love crying
i don't love crying and it's the sort of
thing that makes me cry
i get why you're crying too katie tur
joins us we should note that in response
to the conversation about abuse tony
your dad had no response to us katie
your dad your dad your dad said i know
i'm trying to navigate that said that
she was under extraordinary pressure in
the news business and quote if the kids
felt i was intimidating i apologize i
did the best i could
katie it's so good to have you here i
finished a book on friday i had to stop
myself from calling you because i didn't
want to sound like a stalker since i
knew that you were coming
but you know all of this stuff is so
hard to talk about what was your process
in deciding what you were going to share
and not share you talk about physical
abuse emotional abuse meeting tony it
was really hard but it was the middle of
the pandemic and i was feeling really
lost i
um was wondering if i was in the right
career if i should quit my job i was
thinking that maybe this wasn't what i
was supposed to do maybe it was only
what i ended up doing because it's what
my parents did and what felt familiar
and i was a bit of a head case and in
the middle of this my mom sends a hard
drive with all of that footage that you
just saw and so much more
and
it was a journey going back into it it
was confronting a lot of the stuff that
i had been running away from for
15 16 years and we should say your dad
was very famous your parents they got
iconic video the o.j simpson bronco case
reginald denny being bit beaten in los
angeles you saw this up close and
personal yeah and you tried to run away
even from this career well i did because
i thought you know
what they did was so all-consuming they
were never home you know they were
always on the run we would go to
restaurants and we'd eat in 20 minutes
or 10 minutes or five minutes because if
the scanner would light up then we would
be on to another story we just couldn't
sit still but more than that i mean that
was fun it was cool but more than that
it destroyed them
in the end the business tore them apart
their relationship was a mess my dad
clearly took on all of that stress and
didn't deal with it well
um and and i just thought i should do
something stable something that i know
will work out like be a lawyer or a
doctor
but then you meet tony decouple and you
write in the book and everything changes
you right you make the first move to a
guy that you've said we had to work
together during the pandemic nate and
she says somebody who was farting who
was burping who was napping while i was
on tv he sounds like a real gym yeah i
think i wouldn't catch right there
rough draft stands for tony that's yeah
didn't i x out that paragraph yeah in
the final draft i might have tried and i
put it back in no
broken pieces we do we did the show in
the basement and i would be on the air
covering we're in the middle of the
pandemic and he'd be down there
ostensibly working work on a script and
you would just do horrible things
all right yeah very true tony it worked
it worked yes the romance at the heart
of this is that when i met you i did not
think i was gonna meet anybody and nor
did i think anyone would particularly
want me and i said in one of our early
dates that that i'm you know i'm broken
and i'm i'm rough in certain places and
i said i'm indented i'm dead
and i said well what if our two tents
come together if they can guess i know i
love that but aren't we all we're all
dented which is why this is beautiful
and we appreciate your transparency in
this book you mentioned that as a child
you felt like a fraud
i feel like as adults these things
resurface
how do you resist the urge to have those
same feelings that you felt as a kid not
easily and before she answers i'll just
say she's put on a smile here and she's
standing up tall but i put a note on the
on the on the bathroom mirror because
this is hard for you you would love to
stay in bed all day and not talk about
this stuff still to this day yeah i mean
i struggled a lot with writing the book
and with coming out with the book
because it's it's while it is so much
fun and so interesting and it tells us
so much about journalism and how we got
from there to here and it communicates a
lot of what we are dealing with right
now in terms of the way that we do our
jobs and the way people see us
um it was also
you know a
difficult childhood and i didn't want to
come out here and
i i don't want to condemn my dad and say
that my dad was nothing but bad because
that's not true i love my father i love
my father but you too we have so much
fun together we are not speaking and
that's what makes it harder because i
wish the relationship was better um
i wish it was better yeah yeah but maybe
maybe maybe this will be i mean you also
talk about your career which i also
think is fascinating because i've
followed your work for a long time but
at one point a news director says to you
your boobs are too big in your tv
clothes or do you have stripper shoes i
mean stuff that it's just mind-blowing
yeah today i think there are a lot of
female journalists women in general who
can identify with those conversations
who have been told some version of that
in their career they don't look right or
they look too good or not good enough or
hey we're doing a story on pole dancing
as exercise you have stripper shoes but
my favorite part is motto why be happy
when you can be great that's what your
motto used to be now it's why not be
great and happy great and happy
and that's what you are hard not to be
great and happy with tony i agree i love
you very much now which of our memoirs
do you think the kids will read first i
hope oh gosh good question i think
they'll never read either one they're
not going to read any of them thank you
thank you so thank you it's not easy but
it's so good it's so good i see a movie
here katie katie's memoir don't you i
really do call rough draft it's coming
out tomorrow wherever you like to buy
your books